بالبرود الروسيه على تخوم خركيف
الاوكرانيه في صداره التطورات منذ اسابيع
كانت في بدايه الحرب مركزا لوجستيا
ومنطلقا لمهاجمه روسيا لخاركيب وازييوم
والتقدم شرقا
تكرر استهدافها من الاوكرانيين وتبول
مسلحين فيها حتى قال حاكمها ان حمايتها
تكمن في ضمير انفجار وصف بالكبير جنوبيه
رصدته وسائل اعلام روسيه كما تعرضت لمدينه
لقصف اوكرانيا اوقع اصابات وفق حاكم
المقاطعه الذي وصف الوضع خصوصا في شبكينيو
بالمعقد نافيا وجود اي قوات اوكرانيه على
اراضيها لكن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قال ان القوات الروسيه احمد طز
ثلاثه محاولات اختراق نظمتها تشكيله
اوكرانيه وصفها بالارهابيه في المقاطعه
[موسيقى]
حاولت تشكيلات ارهابيه اوكرانيه معززه
بالدبابات اقتحام الاراضي بمنطقه
تاغولوجانكا السكنيه ونقطه العبور الدوليه
شبينكو احبط جنودنا ثلاثه هجمات شنتات تلك
التشكيلات
[موسيقى]
واقعه مركز الروسي فيها وعلى جبهه اخرى
قال المتحرك باسم قوه الشرق الاوكرانيه ان
قواته تصدت لجميع المحاولات الروسيه
بالتقدم على محور الايمان كوبيانسك شرقي
البلاد خرسون المقاطعه الجنوبيه بدورها
تعرضت لقصف روسي شمل معظم اراضي المقاطعه
ولم تسلم منه ايضا كل من نيكولايفولوجيا
شمالا اسرع اعتياديا اعلان حاله التاهب
الجوي القصوى في العاصمه كييف ومناطق
الشماليه البلاد حيث تحدثت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه عن اسقاط دفاعاتها لعشره
صواريخ باليستيه روسيه من طراز اسكندر وفي
حين سرع الرئيس الاوكراني يبردو لتجديد
مطالبته بتعزيز الدفاعات بلاده الجويه
اعلن البنتاغون وفي احدث التصريحات ان
المساعدات الامريكيه الجديده
تتضمن انظمه ستينجر المضاده للطائرات
وضخائر اضافيه لنظامي باتريوت وهيمارس
[موسيقى]